and you know you go into places like
that I always think of the archetypal
diner in that way you know you guys have
been in this diner there's a really good
opposite diner and there's a great video
on YouTube it's Tom Waits reading
reading a poem by Bukowski and I think
it's called nirvana and it's about a
good diner that he happened to visit
Bukowski happened to visit when he was
on a bus when he was a when he was a kid
a diner where everything was going well
and you could listen to that it's great
I think it's great but this is the
opposite diner I'm thinking wow so
you'll go into a diner right it's 7
o'clock in the morning and you order
some bacon and eggs and some toast and
then you look around in the diner and
you think it was like 1975 when the
windows were last washed and there's
this kind of thick coating of who gives
a damn grease on the on the walls you
know and and the floor too has got that
sort of stickiness that you really have
to work out to develop over years you
know and the waitress is she's not happy
to be there and the guy behind the
counter isn't happy that that happens to
be the waitress that he's working with
and then you know you walk down the
stairs maybe to the washroom and that's
its own little trip and so you come back
and you order your damn eggs and you
order your toast in the order your bacon
and then it comes and like the eggs are
too cooked on the bottom so they're kind
of brown and then they're kind of raw on
top and and they're cold in the middle
which is you really have to work to cook
an egg like that man but you can master
that with like 10 years of bitterness
you teach how to cook an egg like that
and then the toast here's what you do
with the toast right you put you take
you take the white bread you know the
pre-sliced stuff that no one should ever
eat and then you put that in the toaster
and you overcook it and then you wait
and then you pop it out of the toaster
and then because it's overcooked you
scrape it off and you knock off the
crumbs so it doesn't look too burnt and
then you wait til it's cold and then you
put cold margarine on it because if you
put cold first of all not butter but if
you put cold margarine on you can also
kind of tear holes in it so that then it
has lumps of bar
in it and it's really dry except where
it's too greasy so that's like your own
little work of art man and then you put
that on the side with the with C with
the eggs and then you have the potatoes
and this is how you cook the potatoes
properly you know so they're leftover
potatoes and you keep dumping new
leftover potatoes into the old leftover
potatoes over weeks and so some of the
potatoes have they're no longer potatoes
right they've have returned to mother
earth huh then you flop them on the
grill and you sort of hide it oh you
burn them a bit I guess and then you
slap them on the plate and Jesus you
don't eat those man that's for sure and
that's the point and then you have the
bacon and you want to make sure you buy
the lowest possible quality bacon not
such let's how you start and then you
throw it on the grill and you don't your
grill has to be overheated to do this
you have to cook the bacon so that it's
raw in places and burnt in other places
and it has that delightful pits like
odor that only really cheap badly cooked
bacon can provide or maybe you use those
little breakfast sausages that no one in
their bloody right mind would let within
15 feet of anything living you know and
then you serve that right and you serve
it with the kind of orange juice that is
only orange in color and then with
coffee that's ah what would you say it
was started too early in the morning
that's the first thing bad quality
coffee started too early in the morning
got cold once or twice and has been
reheated and then you serve that with
whitener like here's your breakfast
it's like no man that's not breakfast
that's hell
no and and you created it and then what
you do if you have a diner like that is
because you have a miserable life if you
have a diner like that and you've really
worked on achieving that is every night
you go home and you curse your wife and
you curse your kids and you well
curse God too for producing a universe
where a diner like yours is allowed to
exist and that's your bloody life